VEJMELKA, HIS 18th STA
SKILL AS WELL.
>> Brendan: OFF THE BOARDS AT
THE NUMBER ONE POWER PLAY IN TH
>> Brendan: FACE-OFF WIN KEEPS
THE PUCK I I
FIVE-HOLE THERE.
AND IT WILL SET THE MAPLE LEAFS
UP ON ANOTHER POWER PLAY WHEN WE
COME BACK.D POTATOES.
JAM AT THE NET.
THIS IS A PRETTY POWER P, PLAYI
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM FOR THE
>> Brendan: HERE'S AUSTON
MATTHEWS.
STILL ON THE ICE DURING THIS
POWER PLAY.
THIRD IN THE LEAGU
I LOVE THAT DOWNLOW W FRONT,, T
HALF A MILE THERE.
BUT IT COMES RIGHT BACK OUT.
AND TH
ONE OF THE BEST IN THE LEAGUE,
SEASON.
SPENT PARTS OF NINE SEASONS
PLAYING PRING THE GLOVES OFF.
>> Darren: BUNTING NOT THAT TYP.
SHELDON KEEFE THERE.
>> Darren: H SECONDS TO GO.
FOUR ON FOUR TIME. SKATES.
COMES  AFTERMATH,
AUSTON MATTHEWS TAKES A HOOKING
PENALTY.
SESE
SAVES.
THAT'S EARLIER TONIGHT.D
THE REBOUND BEFORE
TAMPA.
THE LOSSES HAVE BEEN SCARCE IN
GE
GOSTISBEHERE.
QUICKLY MOVED ACROSS THE ICE.
SENT AHEAD FOR KELLER.
FEEDS GOSTISE AT GIL GILMORE, J
>>GOSTISBEHERE TO COMMIT.
ONCE HE DOES SO,.
AUSTON MATTHEWS FROM JAKE
SPACE FOR KELLER SO FAR IN THIS
GAME.
BUT IT O.
AND HE SCORES!
Y SOUND PLAY.
SCHMALTZ IS WAITIN.
MATTHEWS WEAVING AROUND IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
NO PLAY TO BE MADE.
PUTS IT ON THE